Hey, I'm Wheels.
Yes, they call me that
on account of the wheelchair.
It's a little on the nose,
but I like it because it's cool.
Okay.
You probably think I'm in the chair
'cause my legs are weak,
but it's the opposite.
My muscles are so strong
my bones can't support 'em.
But lucky for me,
my brain's the same way.
It's supercharged,
so I'm good.
So, Wheels, who's your new friend?
Missy, this is Noodles.
We call him that because, well…
He stretches and twists around
like a noodle?
Yeah, basically.
And that's Ojo.
Her power is she's a genius drawer.
Like Van Gogh mixed with Monet
with just a sprinkle of Salvador Dali.
Can I see that?
A kid standing on top of floating chairs?
An exploding exercise ball?
Nothing she draws makes sense.
[Missy] That me?
-Why'd you draw me in front of the class?
-Oh, she won't answer.
She only speaks through her drawings.
♪ Don't speak
I know just what you're saying ♪
No, you don't.
You have no clue.
what she is saying
And this is A Capella.
-It me.
-That's your superpower? You can sing?
Yep, but I have an unusual range.
I can go low… [sings very low]
or I can go high! [sings very high]
I can even go really…
[inaudible]
I don't hear anything.
It's beyond human hearing.
[feedback]
[Granada] Miss A Capella Vox,
please refrain from using your high voice.
Every dog in the neighborhood
has surrounded our building.
[laughter]
And she can sing so low
that she moves objects.
Show her how you make things float!
[sings very low]
[gasps]
All righty, let's see who's left.
That's Blinding Fast's kid, Slo-Mo.
[Wheels] He's actually moving very fast,
but somehow,
his powers have him stuck in a time warp.
[slowly] Hi.
That kid over there…
Two packs of candy for crossing our eyes.
…is Facemaker.
Okay.
Beat that.
He makes the craziest faces.
It's impossible!
I can even change my face
to look like you.
[crunching]
He's cheating! I can't compete with that!
Oh, dude!
Rewind, clean up on aisle two.
That's Rewind.
He can rewind time but just a few seconds.
[winding back]
[Facemaker screams]
They're twins. It's crazy, right?
What twins? What are you talking about?
Fast Forward, are you at it again?
You were taking so long, I skipped you
forward a bit. Sorry, not sorry.
She and Rewind are twins.
Opposite powers.
The only thing they agree on
is they don't like each other.
-At all.
They're twins. It's crazy, right?
And then,
there's our fearless leader, Wild Card.
There's not a single power
in the world he doesn't have.
True.
Sure, he has every power imaginable,
but since he can't focus his energy,
they show up randomly.
Also true…
until now that is.
Teleport!
[siren wails]
And last, but definitely not least,
Guppy.
How are you making that?
My mommy is Lavagirl,
but my daddy is Sharkboy.
So instead of lava, I move water.
[sizzling]
I need hydration for my powers to work.
[gasping]
-[Missy] That's really cool.
-[giggling] Thanks.